das mit
tapeten streifen arbeiten
in die rings und die riechen gut das ist
mein
leben
heute gibt es wieder eine neue folge mit
einem albanischen pro megawatt ist
nämlich jetzt einfach mal es ist
los
blunier zwei mehr euch freuen sie sich
jetzt ein paar monate gedauert also für
alle die dich jetzt nicht kennen ständig
mein zwei sätzen vor high noon im rennen
sonst für herrn megawatt das war schon
okay das ist glaub im laufe des videos
werde ich ihn aus kräften und meine
haare also die heute noch die findet er
dich retten kommentare und ich hab
klemmung nach innen drinnen draußen also
kann einfach außen drehen aber ich finde
schon dass man sagt man sie zufällig
natürlich jetzt klicken noch falsch
gemacht appétit nächsten videos nicht
immer so hier und meine chance abdi neue
den weg gelegt werden auch haben wollte
er macht ein termin freunde
du sprichst an ihr müsst auf jeden fall
mal auch clooneys profil geht und ich
versuche es so krank wie du schwinden
kann machen wir es auch später am ende
des weges kreis gefahren noch ein
komplettes makeover
betrieb also und was machen wir heute ja
wie guck mal was albanische was hab ich
dir beigebracht hier
ein warnschussarrest traditionelles
montiert meine damen und herren man pia
ich kenne man da auf türkisch ja es ist
interessiert das selbe den teig gefüllt
mit fleisch aber die türkische wird zum
beispiel gekocht im russischen wird auch
gekommen dann heißt das man diamanten
man tut also keine agentur afghanischen
art also das rezept ist von loni heute
ich schreibe euch trotzdem die
mengenangaben so bald ich kann in die
infobox würde machen das ja ich will
meine fans voll somit geht kennen die
mitglieder hat man ja ja mit gläserner
noch meine machen aber eigentlich unsere
gefühle arbeit aber es im prinzip nur
schwer okay wir startet mit dem teig ich
hole uns kurz
ja ich hole künftig das ist schon
anstrengend da warst du ausgesucht hast
ja deswegen
lassen wir sind ein bisschen helfen aber
dann später wird's ja später motor
handarbeit okay ich hole die maschinen
und dann geht's los ich hab das okay
ich habe jetzt sind wir bereit das
rezept so bombig sagt die allein schon
wegen dieses
ich weiß es nicht aber ist auch er war
sehr traditionell
streichen
als dealer und herren und zwar gezielt
erstmal wasser hier ein
lauwarmes wasser ganz wichtig glaube ich
nur so ich glaube ich sind zweieinhalb
von denen wir haben wasser da kommt
jetzt mehl salz und im wissen öl einfach
keinen worden sei wird gute alte bad
reichenhaller sein
müssen ja auch so mit hand so ich würde
sagen so ein bis zwei esslöffel eine
coole eine innere hand co2 reingemacht
verliefen wenn gar nichts nur was war
mail lassen wir sind so eine albanische
rezepte die sie sagen also bauern
rezepten wie man nicht viel hat oder
nicht viel gebraucht hat aber es hat
wirklich gut schmeckt und das ist halt
wirklich nur mehl salz wasser und ich
heute mal ein bisschen irgendein nicht
mal öl kommen drei monate so ein
bisschen ein bisschen bis ich weniger
wir nehmen jetzt hier sonnenblumenöl
einsätze haben wir das mehreren tausend
kneten ja nochmal rein einfach ein ja
immer
ihr müsst so viel mehr benutzen wie
bisher krankheit fest es ist
gerade am kneten aber wir sind schon
fast fertig entwickelt er darf einfach
nicht mehr kleben das ist so geil wie
schön mit so
richtig man sagt ja auch bei uns sagen
die mir wenn das wieder ein ohrläppchen
sich anfühlt dann ist das richtig
nix da nichts mehr das
müsse nicht vorstellen kann dass wir so
ein bild einblenden vorher nachher jetzt
und nachher wir kommen werden wir darauf
zurück wie
das geschäft sehr sehr gern ich glaube
da und wir bekommen es so oft noch
fragen explizit nicht weil viele leute
echt auch das problem haben sage ich mal
und ich sehe offen drüber redet fangen
wir doch mal andere zur überhasteten in
den magen jetzt ich hatte letztes jahr
august tatsächlich vor einem jahr quasi
lag bei passt habe dadurch hat sehr viel
abgenommen ich war sehr übergewichtig
aber nicht gesehen also 170 jahren in
rheine die bilder so siehst dann nämlich
live kennt wird man auch nicht denken
dass ich schon als 70 kilo gewogen und
jetzt sicherlich skeptisch ich glaube
ich nur 298 8
nochmals um das gewicht sagt ja auch
nicht so viel weil das ding ja auch
muskeln machen ich habe richtig schwere
knox haben meine ausbildung
aber ich hab echt viel abgenommen da
durch das war nicht einfach es war schon
hart also man muss sich schon so
wirklich amt befassen mit dem thema und
sehr sehr mental darauf vorbereiten aber
es macht auf jeden fall mache und ich
habe mittlerweile sehr viele leute
meinem freundeskreis auch aber auch so
bekannt und soll ich es gemacht haben ja
auch sehr zufrieden sind deine als
besser vertragen die andere weniger das
kommt wirklich mal auf den menschen an
aber das ist ganz schön prozessen wie
kann man es jetzt fast ein halbes jahr
oder bruder ist es schon du also
dauerhaft klar der magen ist ein muskel
der vergrößert sich dann auch mit der
zeit wieder jetzt kann ich mittlerweile
mehr essen und trinken als am anfang
aber kommt doch auf die op art weil es
einen schlauchwagen in bypass dann gibt
es in magenballon es gibt wirklich so
ganz viele verschiedene arten ich hatte
jetzt den bei mir weil eingriff ein
bisschen aufwendiger sag ich mal ich
hasse schon erst zu den eingriffen
deutlich gibt immer die hälfte des tages
nochmals zu tun haben
ja gar nicht haben doch hier nichts
macht
euro also du hattest deine ok in
deutschland ja ich habe sie in berlin
machen lassen viele machen das auch im
ausland aber ich war mir so unsicher so
ein bisschen ausland weilen wird dadurch
leichter sprache da nicht genau sprechen
und so deutsche erste
den kann man vertrauen auf jeden fall
und wie war das denn wie viel kalorien
durftest du danach essen die sache ist
du kannst danach nichts essen und ich
habe wirklich so die ersten sechs wochen
post operativ habe ich mich von drei
teelöffeln joghurt und käse dreimal am
tag aber so zum beispiel morgen habe ich
drei teelöffel zucker löffel joghurt
gestern aber gestoppt und das war schon
so komisch für mich so ein bisschen
diese umstellung aber warten jetzt ist
aber hattest du auch appetit noch andere
sache ist appetit hat er nichts mit
hunger zu tun so aber dieses mehr so vom
auge und du musst halt dann du musst ein
wirklicher in deinen augen blitzen dein
gehirn dringend hey du hast kein hunger
nur du willst essen bei mir weil du
kannst du auch nichts essen und wenn du
viel ist oder für trinks dann schmerzt
dann pläne und habe immer noch gefühl
gäste und ich hab ich ja wirklich so
traf damit beschäftigt und hab halt
erfolg damit gehabt und jetzt bist du
natürlich auch thorsten angeblich ja
hier glücklich das war die beste
entscheidung meines lebens getan haben
führt direkt an dass man ein ganz
anderes lebensgefühl keiner muss drin
sein kann er mutig sein wie man es wohl
fühlt ich persönlich habe ich einfach
mal betreten meiner haut zwar zu viel
auch gesundheitliche wahlen teilnahm
nicht mehr schön nicht gut aber ja so
freue wir sind den teig den haben wir
abgedeckt
welt geworden ganz wichtig wir brauchen
zwiebeln können einfach so zwei drei
große zwiebel nehmen oder mehrere kleine
je nachdem wir müssen gerieben werden
geschrieben weil wir brauchen den saft
erzählt am ende zu dem fleisch schön am
geschmack ich finde dass
ich kann ihn an mainz abgeben nicht erst
kürzlich
war meine albanischen tv show neben der
kochshow immer mein traum eine talkshow
zu gehen und dann war das war letztes
jahr waren wir so ein projekt dort habe
ich gekauft habe ich auch gemacht
vielleicht gar nicht mal auch alle so
einige titel machen kann ist
also wenn ich mir richtig mühe geben
meyer und herren wir benutzen natürlich
unsere speziellen sofortiges geht es mit
einer wunderschönen beschichtung da
brennt nichts an und wärme verteilt sich
sehr gut natürlich ein major und
herren
wir braten infizieren sehr sehr gut an
das muss sehr gut angebraten werden dann
fügen wir das fleisch hinzu und dann
wird auch noch mit sehr wenig gewürzt
pfeffer salz
liter wein gibt nichts
deswegen war mir leid wenn du dir geht
sagen hast uns natürlich von kik
sketchen eigenmarke paprika edelsüß wer
du bist jetzt warten dass das warten ja
aber in manchen fragen höre dann auch
beim thema magen bypass land wie ist es
eigentlich mit
nahrungsergänzungsmitteln weil ich war
ja da muss man irgendwie irgendwas zu
seit jahren also ich nehm vitamine ich
musste jetzt mein leben lang phasen da
muss ich jetzt mal so krass vitamine und
zählen immer vitamine im körper ob du
jetzt deine schwarzkümmelöl nimmst oder
sonst was immer man braucht immer was im
körper beziehungsweise ungefähr immer
was er habe nicht fehlen so bestimmt wie
damit erreichte durch die nahrung nicht
mehr aufnehmen kann dadurch ist sehr
wenig esse und mein magen die sehr
schnell ich sagen verdaut habe ich halt
mich dieses was normale menschen ist
eine maler mark hat das dass die
nährstoffe vom wagen in also vom essen
entnimmt dadurch dass nämlich sehr viel
fleisch essen kann weil dadurch sehr
schnell voll werde nämlich mal so alle
drei monate so eine b 12 also das ist
gar nicht so dass sie morgen mit 1000
cups in einer eigentlich habe jeden
morgen eine tablette und dann
zwischendurch bisschen kalzium und man
muss halt wirklich drauf bei meinem arzt
checken lassen so was fehlt dir deinen
körper oder hast du wirklich von
gitarrist ein halbes jahr oder ja ist
schon besonders jedes halbes jahr macht
aber ich bin ehrlich was jetzt nicht
also ich fühle mich pudelwohl ihr fehlt
nicht aus deinen körper genau ich hoffe
es ist immer wichtig auf seinen körper
zu hören als immer auf die ärzte zu
hören naja ihr habt glaube ich auch
diese kapseln richtig gut
das ist auch gut frauen denn dann kommen
wir zurück zu meinen beruf da ich auf
reserven wenn man ein problem hat mit
haarausfall ist ersten gras sehr sehr
gut für die haarwachstum und leute denen
das nicht schmeckt mit dieser goldene
milch zum beispiel könnte als sehr gut
und kapseln zu den gästen merkte auch
richtig wachsen überall haben wenn man
schon den kammerspielen
nägel genau was auch viele fragen sich
auf instagram viele haben gefragt wie
viel das denn überhaupt noch am tag
essen umgingen also ich esse so viel
geschaffen doch ich kann ich habe es
keinen kein kalorienzähler kein gramm
zählt aber sonst was ich esse so viel
wie mein körper brauchen wie ich kann
und das ist auch wichtig ja weil so
wenig ist man muss halt wirklich mit der
psyche muss sehr gut spielen können und
du sagst ja auch nicht ab hungern also
du sollst so viel essen wie du kannst
und du merkst du auch was sein körper
besser verträgt oder nicht die blase und
joghurt geht kannst du mehr erst jetzt
die fleisch ist aber wenn ich dann ich
es auch noch ein weg ist oder sogar fast
food oder dann erst am nächsten tag bis
zum meer sala hat oder das andere marken
eigentlich ja mal ist verhallt nun mit
weniger was leider auch kein meister
liegt es dem nächsten wichtig an der
stelle zu sagen ja auch viele leute zu
was man sagt man soll jetzt nicht
irgendwie sein leben dann auch nichts
achten gerade gesundheitlich und dann
sagen hören aber das soll das war kein
zuckerschlecken
es war nicht einfach und sehr sehr
wichtig man kann mit der op wieder
zunehmen okay also es ist kein
freifahrtschein ist eine hilfe klar es
ist einfach eine hilfe für leute ich
sag's eigentlich den mund nicht zu
kriegen weil auf dem etikett ist nichts
anderes außer du kannst nichts mehr
helfen so entweder machst du selber und
hört einfach auf zu essen oder du machst
hat die ok wenn du selber nicht was ich
etwas stehe bei vielen leuten vor allem
auch noch und es ist nicht einfach weg
zu sein und dann abzunehmen es ist
wirklich einfach meinen frauen kämpfen
mit fünf kilo so aber kommt aber die 50
klarheit und wenn du dann in so ein loch
fällt und das ist nicht einfach auch für
die leute ich kann's halt wirklich
nachempfinden wie es halt ist ist es
machbar ist auch ok machbaren aber es
hat eine gute hilfe aber sollte sich
wirklich zeit lassen gut überlegen uns
ist sehr gut also dass wir in diese
phase des lebens am eintauchen
das ist ja nicht nur so private kunden
sondern auch viele promis ja für ein
paar aus ich arbeite für mit new camera
und somit bekannten leuten ich hab's
vielleicht bin ich denke die lehrer nun
habe ich die haare gemacht logo dann hab
ich ja daran gemacht eine zeit lang dem
einen oder anderen habe ich auch schon
zusammen gearbeitet also sollten
neben ja so ein bisschen ab dass ich
meine musik musikvideos sind halt
wirklich teure produktion und große
produktionen dann muss man halt auch
dementsprechend gut aussehen und wenn du
dann halten wir die leute von regal
überhaupt nicht es gibt so viele männer
die sich schminken oder zum beispiel
concealer drauf machen weil leute die
haben viel arbeitet hat auch schon
länger und finde ich auch nicht zb
chanel hat eigene linie für herren raus
und wenn ja was ich gar nicht so schlimm
klingt und ist auch nicht verbergen weil
rat wenn du das wissen ja beträge
manchmal da willst du nicht an
augenringe sparen
ich habe meine ausbildung nach 2016 als
friseur gehabt während meiner ausbildung
hätte mal so montags meinem freien tag
den habe ich dann geopfert nach beim mac
gearbeitet
habe dann zwei jahren mac cosmetics
gearbeitet und dann habe ich so ein
knappes jahr für die jorge arbeitet und
nach dem habe ich mich selbstständig
gemacht bei st wirklich so an immer mehr
aufmerksamkeit zukam und die leute
wollen dich mehr und dann habe ich
gesagt hey jetzt ist der zeitpunkt ich
kann mich selbst nicht wahr ja und habe
es dann noch geschafft hatte du hast so
eine frisur ausbildung gemacht ja und
was ist mit make up muss das parallel in
make aber wir zum größten teil selber
beigebracht ich habe viel in den jahren
mitnehmen können durch andere make up
artisten weil ich finde du kannst von
mir lernen ich kann von dir dein marc
anthony in seinem in seinem bereich
sagen ich bin der beste oder ich kann
alles weil niemand kann alles das habe
ich habe ich auch viel von anderen
gelernt und will jetzt doch nicht an
einem touch schreien weil drogenmarkt
sind nicht so ok das hat lohne
geschminkt nicht dass du deine eigenen
städte jeder seine eigene unterschrift
wollen wir jetzt
sagen es ist soweit
[Musik]
so vielleicht es fertig ist auch völlig
gewürzt ihr könnt es ganz kurz abkühlen
lassen muss aber nicht komplett kalt
sein ich habe mir jetzt so ein stück
laden ja so ein kloß genau
genommen und werden jetzt einfach
ausräumen und ursprünglich nach dem
originalrezept macht man so ganz kleine
bällchen und so sage ich mal fünf stück
oder sechs stück dann hört man aus und
legte dann mit öl schichten übereinander
ich habe eine andere variante mit meinem
mann beigebracht sagt ihre mutter bitte
nicht von ihrer schwiegermutter glaube
ich mit meiner oma das ist im prinzip
das gleiche nur einfacher
wir wollen jetzt erstmal aus
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt hier ein schönes stück
schon sehr dünner
was dann branchenmesse wir machen jetzt
nehme ich daraus eine sonne und zwar
schneiden wir quasi jetzt einfach hier
so rein
[Musik]
das wird spannend was kommt
das ist zwar quasi dasselbe prinzip ich
grade kälter wird klappen jetzt gleich
einfach alle seiten in die mitte und
haben uns einfach diesen aufwand gespart
und erstmal alles kleiner raum und
bleibe aber ein
bisschen sonnenblumenöl überall drauf
machen das ist ganz wichtig
[Musik]
leute bitte es heißt nicht die baustelle
es heißt bau stehen nächste baustelle
bau stehe okay also du kannst du kannst
du kurz noch mal sagen was dein vater
macht beruflich genauso interessieren
was
gar nicht schreiben was glaubt ihr was
geschlossen und sind schwer zu meine
produkte und warum verschiedene
baumaschinen baustelle das eigentlich
und was immer im sommer nach kosovo
fahren aber diesen beiden ländern
wobei zum beispiel die türken geheiratet
ihr alle hier in deutschland aber bei
uns alle immer noch kosovo und ging dann
auch das ist immer so aber unser
treffpunkt die jedes jahr in kosten aber
ich hatte auch schöner meine familie ist
jetzt relativ sehr verteilt sie an tante
in amerika in schweden in deutschland
aber die meisten halt immer noch im kopf
wollen das zieht dann halt macht aber
auch viel unterwegs durch
also die nächste zeit bin ich
ich bin jetzt bald auf ibiza dann in
schweiz habe ich viel zu tun ich war
jetzt vor kurzem noch in der türkei dann
war ich auf spanien auf mallorca hat
ganz cool weil dadurch dass ich halt
sehr flexibel was ich meinem beruf der
welt reisen und die leute drehen ich
mache auf die mit videos und so also für
die kamera hier genau da muss man ja
einiges beachten ich hab ja nicht so
schminken auch ja ja fast schon beachten
dass zeit nicht zuviel marx oder dass es
gut für blende ist hast du keine
scharfen kanten hast kamera schluckt er
viele stimmt also wenn du es stark
geschminkt bis dann wirkt es auf der
kamera nicht so stark aber eine kamera
nimmt ganz anders auf was würdest du
jetzt so bei mir verändern dann nämlich
so sieht das so ein typischer so
alltagslook suppe schmeckt auch noch die
kamera
gleich bisschen mehr concealer wir sind
er deswegen auch sehr schnell weg ja und
was hast du dich bei uns aktuell zeit
lang habe ich alle tape mitgemacht aber
ja kennst du hast das auch manchmal dass
du ein produkt benutzen du bist davon
richtig krass überzeugt ja und danach
von heute auf morgen geht er künftig
mehr kauft es dann nach und nach etwas
ist nicht wie am anfang ein concealer
zum beispiel der lange steht der verein
hat ja auch die farbe wieder das liegt
ja es wird er auch studiert zum beispiel
auch von bechers oxidiert ja alles
deswegen kann es sein dass dann die
farbe findet man auch schon ein bisschen
die aber wenn ich jetzt ein make-up
auftragen doch nicht denke es passt und
der konstrukt jetzt noch mal eine halbe
nuance dunkler wolle wie ist das auch im
gesicht kommt darauf die von welcher
also nicht jede von menschen oxidiert
oder nicht jeder konnte oxidiert merkt
das ja wenn du zum beispiel aufträgt und
gewürz man ganz dicken dunkel aber jetzt
nicht so dass das jetzt nicht die farbe
verändert und ich das so eine indiz
dafür dass das produkt ist gut ist wenn
es ob sie die das ist
das ist natürlich also kommt kommt drauf
an ich denke mal klar von dayton sie
nicht abzusehen sind besser weil dann
die farbe nicht verändern aber gerade so
stark deckende foundations und
vollkommen sachen sind immer so ein
bisschen meine kunden gab oder einen
kunden der gesagt hat mit dem ausgleich
nicht
gott sei dank nicht weil ich muss sagen
ich mag es mich ich mag es gar nicht
mich zu pushen aber
ich denke das ist beim make-up das was
mich auch stört bei kollegen und
kolleginnen so die schminke jeden gleich
und muss aber wirklich auch das gesicht
achten muss schauen hey passt dem ihr
schwarzer lied hat mit kosten braunau
lidschatten oder passt dem 1 1 wenn eine
kundin sind sie so augen haben sagst du
einerseits nehmen
die kommt ja weise die vertrauten was
ich schön aussehen werden du kannst dir
haben mit ihr reden sagen hey ich würde
das nicht empfehlen sagt nämlich wird
trotzdem darum mache ich
eigentlich
vertrauen die dann auch immer alle und
am ende sind die wirklich zufrieden
jetzt ist fertig ist so quasi wie ein
hatten an diesem tag der geschichte des
letter tag genau ist so ähnlich wie
blätterteig hab ich jetzt einmal
ausgerollten nicht zu denken und ich hab
jetzt gedacht wie falsch und wird uns
jetzt so richtig zu arbeiten
das waren uns heute bei peta jetzt
schneide ich hier so christian rein
und dem türkischen wird man die jetzt
richtig zu machen diese kästchen aber so
hat man auch ein bisschen weniger
arbeiten ja definitiv plötzlich fragt
warum loni das so gut drauf hast du bist
selber hobbykoch und hobbybäcker na ja
ich liebe es zu kochen zu wirken also
auch merkt man auf jeden fall
ja ich bin das merkt man das ist so du
du du merkst sich diese diese passion
die da drin ist dafür
schon mal drauf wer von euch werfen euch
folgt die noch aus der alten küche mit
den blauen mosaik
fliesen oder wir sagen das war das motto
lautet das mit tapeten
geschichte dazu wir hatten eine
hässliche wirklich alte 20 städten küche
kamen so nicht haben dann 60 euro
zusammengekratzt das war verdammt viel
geld für uns damals und dann waren wir
bei poco glaube ich und haben uns diese
tapete gekauft und noch von mit dem
restlichen geld noch so eine wandfarbe
und noch so dinge leisten und damit
entstand diese berühmte tapeten ich
hoffe immer dass man fliege auf der
täuschung gott ganz kurz nebenbei ich
sehe mir das hat jedes kästchen und
zieht das mal so ein bisschen auf und
wenn sie zum beispiel so ungleichmäßige
habt dann könnt ihr auch zwei
übereinander tun
dann kann man sie zum beispiel nummer 1
schon hat man wieder zwei vernünftige
[Musik]
es ist so wir sind jetzt fertig wir
haben unsere man tiere entwickelt und
sehr schön
platziert auf unseren blech könnte auf
dem runden blech machen also wie sieht's
aus wie eine schnecke dann würde ich
euch empfehlen von außen anzufangen nach
ändern zum abschluss werden den ofen
vorgeheizt auf 250 grad ober und
unterhitze frage wenn einer nicht so
nach dem motto ein schenker manche
gegner nur bis 230 oder zumindest auf
230 zahllosen ja genau einfach ein
bisschen länger
backen lassen ich werde jetzt mit etwas
gestottert die
band ihr schön einpinseln
unten grund haben wir auch butter gemein
hat gesehen wenn du meinst gerade auch
als kameras warten denn die mädchen das
macht man eher so an sondern tagen ja
genauso bei uns wir machen das immer an
beiden zb seinen besonderen tagen halte
über rama tami leicht was ist eigentlich
ein typisches bei haben gericht ja das
ist so tradition einfach feiern bei uns
in meiner fans ist marie tradition
mantey anberaumt zu machen oder wenn was
besonderes ansteht oder so sind meistens
sogar den aufwendigen sachen kleinteile
das ist dann immer an besonderen tagen
so wie heute die nächsten sieben wochen
oder range genauso 20 grad wie lange
willst immer nach gefühl ja also es gab
schon so nach halbe stunde bis man denkt
okay je nachdem wer sogar schneller ich
habe keine zeit gekümmert also ich
schreibe euch auf jeden fall unten
infobox nach machen möchten und wir
stehen uns einfach rein
[Musik]
so räume wir werden jetzt während
unserem land hier backen ein wiki so ein
kleines mac oder geben ich habe mir
überlegt wie machen was ganz anders was
sie nicht hatte und was ihr nicht kennt
von ihr und zwar benutzen wir da für
diese schönen takes das ist ja gerade
der trend ich weiß das nicht ich freue
mich ich habe meine müssen die
originalen tex 100 filme serien und
shops genauer aus diesen superguten
gehalten und bombenfest also den ganzen
tag das ist auch megawatt ist ich habe
viel gelernt und ich sage dir sie war
also meine inspiration und sie hat mich
in den letzten jahren ein bisschen
gepusht auch wirklich viel
zusammengearbeitet und ihre titten
einfach der chip die machen wir jetzt
dran und während der krise und kleines
ein lift geben wenn ich so ein bisschen
verschlafen so
richtig gut das ist mein
also ganz leicht aber es ist ein film
angenehm neue haare aufnahmen sieht man
das ganze nicht mehr
es ist schon mit produkten also jetzt in
the making ich habe jetzt gehe ich ein
bisschen aufgefrischt foundation des
controlling ganz leicht dass man sich
direkt also das ist nun krass dass man
mit diesen augen tipps machen kann
einfach klick jetzt noch nicht selber
gesehen haben so manchen bord kreisten
ja weil es ein bisschen strafbar wenn
man lustig oder hamza
so ich mache jetzt eine neue freundin
ich mach das mal mit pinsel und so
[Musik]
potter
ich habe jetzt in einer lange macht das
mache ich ja noch ein bisschen
lidschatten decrease so ganz ein ganz
leichtes braun der für seine recherchen
eindruck haben sagt es wird heute nicht
natürlich nicht normal ist das ganz
anderen worten meine damen wir sind
fertig das ist hier keine schleife
dann ist da noch mal her ich komm nicht
drauf klar ist dieser mit wie operiert
halo gibis ist dass das kind krank ist
dass die schwester das ist kunst das
coole ist wenn die haare jetzt so auf
lässt sieht man die tabs sonne was meint
ihr schreibt mir jetzt medikamente
weltweit ist schon anlass oder her ist
es anders aber auch wieder nicht zu viel
oder wie ich ihn an weil es das
eigentlich kann man ja auch so jetzt
quasi nur so einen schönen eyeliner und
bist du ein bisschen was stimmiges auf
dem bietet so einen ganz gleichen braun
thronenden der krise kann es halt
wirklich schnell schnell geschminkt aber
das ist nichts
was die wenigsten bekommen bin geschockt
jetzt können wir es
fertig das sind unsere albanischen man
hier gemeinsam mit cookies kitsch
[Musik]
auf jeden fall die meiste arbeit gemacht
da haben wir sehr dankbar daran gewöhnt
sind und lasst uns einfach mal einfach
ein container machen willst du auch mit
uns gleichzeitig testen
ob jemand für die schon sehr knusprig an
so knusprig derby aus einem einfachen
teig dieses schichten sonne geld also
diese ganzen lagen sie ist jetzt auch
was schmeckt ist die bürger tag
irgendwie sowie blätter türken ganz
ehrlich macht unbedingt nach ich habe
wie gesagt mir ganz mengenangaben unten
rein unser talk ist aber noch nicht
vorbei denn wir sind noch zwei fragen
durch den mann geschossen ist los bei
start gewinne du hast schon so auch high
end produkte genutzt und so weiter wie
viel gibt es im monat aus für make-up
ich muss sagen es gibt nicht so viel
make-up aber natürlich man bekommt das
ein oder andere zugeschickt klar sei es
perfekt und so du kaufst du meine
foundation eine high end von dann
benutzt dann halt wirklich so mehrere
malen also es ist nicht so dass ich
einmal benutzern ist der schutz dieser
verschiedene kunden deswegen das ist
eigentlich ist hält sich noch im rahmen
aber es gibt also das sei eine
hausnummer ungefähr im jahr 1000 euro
flächen im jahr 1000 dieser ist damit ja
so viel an und wie gesagt eine
foundation kost sich vielleicht 30 40
euro aber die luft dann auch ein halbes
jahr lang
mainhausen davon 34 stück mischten und
was auch viel auf ins angefragt haben
und das wird mich auch interessieren wo
siehst du dich in 20 jahren ich sehe
mich erfolgreich erfolgreicher als jetzt
bin aber ich kann es nicht so
einschätzen wo ich mich in 20 jahre sehe
weil ich mag sich in die zukunft zu
planen
ich mag es für die zukunft zu arbeiten
schießt also ich will jetzt nicht sagen
hey man solche ziele setzen ja aber mein
ziel ist es so allgemein nicht so ich
möchte dieses produkten 20 jahren
herausbringen sondern ich möchte
produkte in 20 jahren herausbringen ja
was euch überraschungen genau dafür
müsst ihr unbedingt ist hier ist eine
schöne überleitung mit dem losen folge
neben wills freundin also allein sich
schon noch so gerne eine story sun ihr
müsst einfach mal auf instagram den abo
da lassen wenn er auch die
community-seite lasten aber da und dann
verfolgen wir auch weiter den weg
also würde noch mal voll dass wir
zusammen was backen schreibt unten in
den kommentaren man sonst nicht
überlasse das schlusswort danke
zu sagen während führen habe mir danke
fürs zuschauer hatte richtig spaß
gemacht also es war immer mein traum bei
krebs hin zu stehen ihr habt es
ermöglicht also mal komm ich hab die
zugesperrt
vielleicht
[Musik]